ouragan Yann continue d'infliger des
dégâts alors cette fois c'est la Floride
qui subit avec des vents qui vont
jusqu'à 250 km/h qui ont déferlé sur cet
État américain à la Floride des victimes
d'inondation colossales de coupure de
courant après le passage de cette
ouragan catégorie 4 sur 5 près de 2
millions de personnes sont privées
d'électricité et il s'agirait même d'un
des cinq ouragans les plus puissants
jamais passé sur cette
états mon Dieu
les vents à 185 km/h moins que les 250
attendus mais largement assez pour
porter des torrents de pluie et l'eau
dans les villes
ici à Fort meilleur les Russes sont
rapidement transformés en torrents cette
caméra de surveillance placée à un mètre
80 du sol et englouti en quelques
minutes images impressionnante que
relais la presse américaine ce matin
l'image d'un requin qui nage dans les
rues inondées d'une ville de Floride la
Floride balayée depuis hier soir par
l'ouragan Yann plus de 2 millions de
foyers 2 millions ce matin de foyer sans
électricité c'est baigneur inconscient
qui savent qu'un ouragan déchaîné arrive
sur les côtes et qui se disent tiens on
va aller se baigner alors qu'il suffit
d'attendre finalement pour pouvoir se
baigner dans son salon vous voyez cet
habitant de Floride qui pratique la nage
en eau libre mais indoor en intérieur
c'est original c'est une forme de
résilience tu vois il fait
ouvrir
les nuls avaient fait ça je vous signale
à l'époque mais là il décide vraiment il
dessine c'est la forme de l'ouragan
c'est pas c'est pas autre chose
je patiente dans cette chambre noire
j'entends qu'on s'amuser qu'on chante au
bout du couloir
[Applaudissements]
qui elle qui s'est levure et j'épouser
vers le grand jour j'ai vu une femme
et les gens autour la prison depuis des
années moi ce que j'entends c'est que
c'est réinsérer c'est éviter la récidive
c'est le confort dans les prisons la
France est sanctionné machin mais
citoyens français tout ça il en a rien à
cirer
qui ont voté
est-ce que un terroriste et un
pédocrinel c'est un souci citoyen toi tu
dis NON je dis ce ne sont pas des
monstres mais c'est un vrai débat
[Applaudissements]
le a le nom donné au couvercle des
toilettes au-dessus de la lunette
l'abattoir
j'espère pour vous que ça dépend le cas
il s'agit d'un bateau
le gouvernement veut pousser le curseur
de l'âge de départ à la retraite de 62 à
65 ans d'ici 2031 il acceptable pour les
syndicats qui appelaient au
rassemblement aujourd'hui un peu partout
en France à Paris la question des
retraites était dans toutes les têtes 65
ans c'est non et à 3 millions de
chômeurs
[Musique]
et on va faire continuer à travailler
les dieux jusqu'à 35 ans je suis pas
d'accord s'il y a une émotion de censure
qui est votait je dissout tout de suite
voilà ce qu'il a dit hier soir majorité
à l'Élysée en rajoutant je ne veux
surtout pas la chanlie la dernière fois
que quelqu'un a dissout et dissou c'est
pas cher mais la dernière fois c'était
le président
on a les plus belles places
à merveille
j'ai comme un fou rappelez-moi vous
l'aviez trouvé comment la société s'il
vous plaît je m'adresse à l'auditrice à
comment s'appelle-t-elle Sylvie
s'appelle oui
il faut que je me souvienne de 17 non
est-ce que je suis désolé la prochaine
fois j'apprendrai par cœur je coucherai
un petit peu plus tard vas-y fais-moi
Adrienne tu le fais bien
mais c'était pas ma guerre
c'était pas ma guerre réaliser un rêve à
97 ans c'est possible au détour d'une
rue Isaia Guerza star de Tik Tok a
surpris un vétéran de guerre en lui
proposant de l'accompagner à Disneyland
une demande acceptée sur le champ les
deux amis d'un jour ont pu alors
partager un joyeux moment dans le parc
d'attraction entre tours de manège et
rencontre féerique
je pensais que ma vie était finie je me
rappellerai de cette journée pendant
longtemps les États-Unis qui pleure
aussi la mort du rapport Coolio il avait
59 ans si vous êtes né avant les années
2000 vous avez forcément chanté ou
danser sur cette chanson
[Musique]
tube planétaire gangsta's Paradise sorti
en 1995